I
this is I think more than simply the
return of naval rotc to Columbia this is
really an historic moment in which a
breach for all of its different reasons
is repaired is healed that's the way it
should be we think it's terrific
Columbia has a long history of
supporting research and development long
history developing officers for the Navy
and Marine Corps Columbia has by far the
largest community of veterans in the Ivy
League over 600 what I gained out of
rotc both in physical fitness and in
terms of leadership skills and in
management skills really informed and
aided my academic curriculum development
at Columbia and vice versa after I
graduate I'll Commission and I'll become
a commissioned officer United States
Navy I'm committed for five years I
don't know what job will have yet but I
will be finding out soon and i'll
probably be serving in either a surface
platform or submarine platform or air
there are several components so that
we're looking forward to develop over
the four-year course of one's training
to be a naval officer obviously it's a
physical component physical fitness
training there's a moral component
leadership we're looking at carefully at
their developed to ensure they're the
kind of people that we want leading
sailors and Marines out in the fleet and
finally there's a obviously an
educational mental development piece and
columbia university is our partner in
that and we look forward to developing
officers that have the advantage of an
education at an elite institution like
this to join the officer corps I am so
grateful for the education and the
opportunities that Columbia gave me and
for the wonderful experiences that this
community gifted me for those four years
and I'm absolutely thrilled that that
opportunity is going to be given to
future military officers naval officers
in particular as a consequence of naval
ROTC coming back to Columbia we're
delighted to be here we're very thankful
for the generosity of the administration
to welcome us back
to the campus and we look forward to
these men and women joining the officer
ranks in the Navy in the Marine Corps in
the coming years I want to recognize all
the students here for your participation
in Columbia we value you for many many
reasons but one of them is that we think
the diversity of perspectives and
opinions that you bring to the
institution is highly significant I see
it myself in the classes that I teach
you